with the rise of food prices and glow
production we are seeing it more and
more how essential it is to grow your
own food to have a garden today we're
going to show you
how easy it is to take the back breaking
work on having a vegetable garden
if you have a vegetable garden you know
exactly what is going into your food so
no tractor
no problem
here is a plot of land that's never been
plowed or tilled before
except for about 85 plus years ago
and my grandfather did it with a mule so
we can consider that this land has never
been plowed or tilled before
here on to the east coast we have not
had any cold weather this has been about
one of the coldest days we have and you
see i have a flannel shirt on
but
saying that the grass has not died it's
got a lot of greenery this is a lot of
thick grass so it's definitely going to
have to be plowed up
now you should this is january you
should have it piled up at least you
know maybe two months prior to january
it would be a new ground but
nevertheless it's not about the time
frame it's about going ahead and getting
it done today that's what we're going to
do so a gentleman is going to come in
and help me get this plowed up it was
supposed to been played up two months
ago but
uh you know i just had to pull him in
and so he's going to take care of that
after we get it plowed up after you get
your ground plowed up and tilled up then
what you want to do is do a ph test you
want to put lime in there you want to
put fertilizer in there of course you're
going to have to get some rocks maybe
and some sticks and some roots out you
know get it out but the next year it'll
be so much easier i have a garden i've
had for four years and last year it was
so productive i had hardly any grass
into it because the soil is so good so
rich
but i don't have to deal with the rocks
and the sticks and it's just really easy
once you get your garden going it's not
as hard as you think but you do have to
put time in it
what you put in it into it is what you
get out of it how much time you put into
it is how much you're going to get out
of it you put some time into it you're
going to get a great harvest if you're
not able to have
a garden plot maybe it depends on where
you live or maybe a smaller one you
wouldn't believe how much food a smaller
little raised bed would put out
but maybe you're considering a
greenhouse
so let me show you my greenhouse that's
under construction only thing is lacking
is the wiggle wire
and the plastic
so here's the greenhouse
and this is good for like you know
when our time growing when you can't
really get outside you're unable to
really get outside this is this will be
a really good benefit so check out my
video how
to build a low side wall greenhouse now
some people may say this is overkill
but i live in a hurricane zone so within
that we got to make sure that the uh
greenhouse doesn't go rolling so
with this being such a thick grass here
and never been plowed tilled anything
done for it for years and years so it is
pretty much new ground
um
many people take roundup and they kill
the grass before they go in and plow now
i would not advise that because you are
what you eat
that roundup goes in the soil yes it'll
kill the grass but it goes into the soil
and your plants get all its nutrients
from that soil and it goes into your
plants
so the easiest route is really to take a
tractor if you don't own a tractor then
you hire someone like i did to make it
so easy and so practical that you can
just move forward with it
then
after you do your ph put your lime in
your fertilizer in you can cover it up
and finish smothering out this grass
the reason of enlarging my garden plot
is because last year i ran into the
problem because we're running into
different seasons now we don't really
know how the season is going to do but
here onto the east coast of north
carolina we got enormous amount of rain
and it rotted the garden peas and the
potatoes and it took three times for the
garden piece me to get them even come up
now garden peas they do not like the
heat so when the heat starts rolling in
they quit
at the same time the potatoes you know
they was two months late and so with
time they were supposed to be out of the
ground it was time to plant something
else also so i run into a little problem
there so i feel like i need to expand my
garden out so the possibility i won't
have that little problem there if there
is a problem
what i did with the garden peas
it was time to plant rattlesnake beans
and like i said check out that video on
how to plant rattlesnake beans the most
productive bean i have ever grown and
definitely will grow them again got some
dry beans got some seeds for this year
and they were just awesome but when the
garden peas was coming up of course
garden peas you have them on the trellis
somehow a trellis because they're going
to run
in so is the rattlesnake beans with the
rattlesnake beans it was time to plant
them they was two weeks late getting
into the ground so what i did i just
went on the other side of the the garden
peas and i planted some seeds
and with tom the garden peas couldn't
take the heat anymore it was time to get
them out the rattlesnake beans was about
four to five inches tall and then
suddenly they took off
but
if you have a bigger space then you
don't have to run into problems like
that another good idea i did was also is
that i made my garden like a raised bed
i planted my
rows closely together no more than about
two feet now within that you have to go
in there constantly and trim out the
leaves which i did and you throw them to
the soil which it goes back into the
soil which goes back into your plants
it's just a matter you just got to keep
up trimming the leaves but also with
that benefit what created was that the
grass
there was no grass it just was pretty
much smoldered out any grass smothered
out any grass that was trying to come up
with the soil being really healthy and
nourishment it was just it didn't really
take on the grass
but once you get your garden going once
you get your plot going
and you get the grass out many people
don't understand you have to keep the
grass out how much time you put into it
is how much time you're going to get out
once you really get all those grass
roots out then you're not going to have
a big big problem
or if you don't have the time you can
put row cover down and that will help
smother out the grass now the gentleman
is on his way
and he's rolling in soon
to bring in the bring in to help me
to get this situated so i can show you
how easy it is to get your garden
started
no tractor
no problem
[Music]
hey guys i got somebody i want you to
meet
bryce rogers
so i've been called out to cami's farm
her homestead to help her prepare a
garden on ground has not yet been tilled
at least uh there's no record of it ever
having been tilled
75 plus years ago
my grandfather did it actually 85 plus
years ago guys and that's
predates me yeah i wasn't around yeah me
either but you know what guys it's still
new ground
it's for all practical purposes this is
new ground yeah he actually plowed it up
with a mule so back in the day
they had to grow their own food if they
didn't grow up grow it
they didn't get it we're going to be
plowing with approximately 23 mules
today oh wow there's a little more than
your grandpa oh yeah absolutely
absolutely he would be amazed to see
this
so uh we have new grass we've got uh a
soil that hadn't been turned for many
many years and we're going to do it with
a a machine a john deere tractor 23
horse john deere 10 23 e
and an economic piece of tillage a disc
a four foot wide disc they cost about a
third the price of a of a good tiller
and uh obviously a a pto driven tiller
is preferred it's the the right tool for
the job
but it's not economical
so we'll do it today and a few more
passes a little bit more time but just
as well in the end result
so
actually this ground was supposed to
should have been plowed about two months
ago
and um so we're in january right now but
thank god that he's coming in to get
this straightened out but one of the
things that amazed me when you was
talking about roundup because i don't
put like to put round round up into my
soul because you are what you eat but
you told me something about roundup and
the seeds what the farmers do can you
talk about that sure sure to some degree
farmers will frequently use a roundup
ready
plant
a seed that
allows for the use of roundup to kill
off the weeds the undesirable plants
while the desired crop grows through the
roundup
wow
wow so i'm i'm very much into i want to
say organic but sometimes what you think
is organic is not organic that's why
it's so essential for us to start
growing our own food don't you agree
well sure sure right you
you know what you have
when you've grown that product from uh
from a seed yeah
to a fruit to a vegetable yeah so what
is your experience on growing um gardens
have you what is your experience i was
always the laborer i was the uh hard
worker the mule the mule from many
gardens yeah so i've been gardening all
my life ever since i can remember
one time i said i'd never have a garden
because we we had to raise what we ate
and uh but there's something about it
when it when you are a true homesteader
or you're a true gardener it's into your
blood and you cannot get away from it
somehow way another you got your hands
into the dirt so today guys we're
getting our hands into the dirt so let's
get started what do you think sounds
good sounds good
the first thing i'm going to do is
create a border
i could do this with paint with string
or i'm not doing either one of those
today i'm just going to use the disc i'm
going to draw a straight line from end
to end to end
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys we're at the end of the day and
you've seen him doing his job here and i
want him to explain to you what he was
doing
yeah so my name is bryce rogers i i work
with intelligent design
we just picked up a tractor and
not very much equipment we were trying
to get a job like this done with really
cheap equipment or at least cost
effective
the soil was super hard and it just
wasn't getting it done so we had to pick
up a tiller
and a tiller on the back of a tractor
like this took care of this in a little
over an hour yeah yeah
we tried to hit it up again today
we had a lot of rain over the past few
days about 100 percent
100 and uh
you know we're gonna get stuck we can't
even steer so our lines are going all
crazy and stuff and we can't even steer
because it's so muddy
um
but a tiller took care of even the roots
it acted almost like a stump grinder i
had no no problem with the roots and i
was i was really pleased with that a
frontier tiller
so the the old disc arrow will work on
soft soil
uh not the hard compact
soil
so what areas do you actually work out
of how far do you go out you know what
is your expansion of your work
predominantly i work out of jacksonville
jacksonville is my home base uh so i'll
hit up the surrounding areas of
jacksonville north carolina
i got a couple customers in wilmington
that have been really good customers so
i come down to wilmington frequently and
uh and i try to work in multiple jobs
when i end up driving this far it's an
hour and a half drive so yeah an hour
and a half to come out and until the
garden probably wouldn't be profitable
for either one of us yeah but i'm
already in the area right and i'm in
castle hanging north carolina onto the
east coast of north carolina so um but
yeah so he you know you got to work it
you know
hey guys this is the end result and i'm
so pleased his telephone number will be
down into description
so what is your telephone number yeah my
telephone number 765-242-6833
and i just started a facebook business
page intelligent design i don't know how
you find that other than facebook search
yeah they can find it they're good i'm
probably smart yeah yeah absolutely well
guys thank you so much for watching
please subscribe and hit that like
button and hit that bell so you'll know
when the next video is rolling up and i
appreciate you so much for watching
thank you so much all my subscribers and
i'm so happy with this situation now
this is my second garden i've been
working on
my other garden getting it amended
getting it ready to plant
possibly potatoes and peas and
this one would be this first year so
we're gonna test the ph into it see how
it's gonna roll this year i think it's
gonna do awesome but your first year you
just gotta get the planting just put it
out there and see what it does and in
the second year you'll know exactly
what you're up against and i think it's
going to turn out well because this soil
here looks pretty good i just got to
find out what i'm lacking and what i
need into it and just put the seed in
the ground so i advise you get the
growing thank you so much for coming
thank you so much i'm so happy y'all i
got i got a garden i got it going it's
going on is going on at the homestead
love y'all guys see you on the next
video
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody i am so excited for this
day we are breaking ground here onto the
homestead and i want to meet
hey everybody i am so excited for this
for this
[Music]
hey guys i am so excited for this day we
are breaking ground here onto the
homestead and i want you to meet
somebody and i want you to give him a
shout out in your area
okay just bear with me just introduce me
see
hey everyone i am so excited about this
day we are getting
what happened
did you see that
i don't know what happened today
you